the rising political tension in Saudi
Arabia could lead to an increase in gas
prices new video shows some of Saudi
Arabia's richest and most powerful
people sleeping on cots with rifles
behind them while being detained at a
ritz-carlton hotel many top Saudi
officials were arrested over the weekend
in what's called a sweeping corruption
probe bianna golodryga is here with how
the turmoil could have a global impact
beyond a good morning good morning that
video is incredible officials now say
some 500 people have been detained it's
a royal purge that has roiled oil prices
and threatened geopolitical stability
members of the royal family have been
detained at a five-star ritz-carlton in
Riyadh since the unprecedented weekend
arrests 32 year old Crown Prince
Mohammed bin Salman says this is part of
the effort to root out corruption from
the kingdom the question for investors
is is this a sign of a major reform
effort that's needed to be done or
should we be concerned about internal
instability commodity expert Halima
Croft says the oil market is concerned
about Mideast geopolitical risk driving
up prices so how significant is this for
America I think it's significant because
it's a global market and so if we do see
a problem in a major production zone we
will feel the effects at the pump in
terms of higher prices bin Salman has
focused on revitalizing the economy by
broadening investments and introducing
economic reforms Robert Jordan is a
former US ambassador to Saudi Arabia
I think the Crown Prince is legitimately
trying to bring his country into the
21st century bin Salman played host to
President Trump on his first trip abroad
where the two men were said to have
bonded the president has expressed
confidence in the new leadership the
events of this past few days I think are
something that we have to all carefully
watch the Saudis feel somewhat empowered
I think by the Trump administration to
take very strong measures
to calm economic concerns the crown
prince directed Saudi ministers on
Tuesday to ensure that national and
multinational companies were not
disrupted including those tied to
individuals under investigation that
includes Prince Alwaleed bin Talal he's
called the Warren Buffett of the Middle
East and just to check last night I went
online to see if there were any rooms
opening anytime soon at that
ritz-carlton no availabilities until
mid-december so it may give us a sense
of how long these men will be under
lockdown no one has heard from Prince
Halloween right not that we know of it
is said that they're not allowing phone
calls to come into the hotel yeah yeah
you just don't think of a rest in
ritz-carlton in the same sentence
anywhere very fast not too many people
do that's right
you can be on up